this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today as we've had a lot of requests
for it he's going to be breaking down
the mad guns
of battlefield 1. i have to chuckle at
the um
dainty way that the character handles
the thing and sort of
squeezes it between his thumb and
forefinger this thing would have
zero stopping power if there are any
other games guns or mechanics that you
guys want to see jonathan break
down do let us know in the comment
section down below and make sure to
subscribe for more videos exactly like
this
and of course if you want to help out
the royal armies museum and continue to
support jonathan's work
be sure to check out the links in the
description of this video right
over to jonathan
um i suppose the first thing to say
about battlefield 1 in general and about
this first weapon in particular is it
was never used
there are so many guns in battlefield 1
barely exists
i almost think of it as a sort of
steampunk alternate reality
first of all that i'm that i'm playing
in when i play bf1
that's out of the way uh the hell regal
is
it is probably the least real gun in the
game
in the sense that there's no real
example
there are only some really nicely taken
photos
of i mean for all i know the only
prototype and that's the nice thing
about bf1 is there's a showcase these
roads not travelled if you like the hell
regal is one of these
very early attempts at a submachine gun
before we really know what a submachine
gun is
and it's it's got a a box to contain uh
a belt of ammunition and i don't believe
the box is attached to the weapon
feel free to charge me in the comments
if i'm wrong on that
which means it's a light machine gun
firing a pistol-type cartridge
more than this here's the submachine gun
as we see it used
in the game but i totally see why they
went for it
[Music]
pause bulkheart c93 this is a a really
really nice self-loading pistol from the
the 1890s as the name would it as a
designation would imply designed by um
hugo burkhart
who would go on with george luga to
create the luger pistol it shares a lot
of features
push button magazine release you see
that being used in the game with a sort
of
jaunty kick of the hand to throw out the
magazine that would work that's quite a
slack fit in there
at the time i imagine it would have been
a more sedate remove the magazine
replace the magazine
um speed reloads were not a thing in
1918 and the way we see it used in the
game there is
one hand like this pretty much um and
you see that the mainspring
and a lot of the bolt is hanging over
the back of the hand doesn't look and
feel too awkward when you're playing bf1
but in real life this thing is
incredibly unbalanced like all things
you could get used to it but
it needed um luger's savvy to come in
and
build all of this into the gun move
everything forward a bit
shorten the barrels you don't need that
long barrel for a pistol
and come up with a a really good design
in the luger
but he drew a lot of it from the c93
so we've got the here the m1918 modelo
1918
beretta submachine gun well depicted in
the game i think
i don't know the rate of fire
specifically for this but it stands to
reason it would be quite
high the bolt is quite small top mounted
magazine as we see there
the reload i get from memory and from
from the video
it doesn't look too bad but um as you
can see here it actually
there's a log on the back of the
magazine and it rocks in forward
in the reload animation it seems to me a
bit more like they're jamming it in
straight from the top which wouldn't
work you wouldn't get your gun reloaded
that way
but um yeah so this this has perhaps
more right to be in bf1 than
other guns in the game and it's rumored
suggested that some made it to the
to the uh front in 1918 with the italian
army
i i would have to on the side of caution
say this was too late
for the first world war but only just
was it there now the bergman mp18
definitely did see use in the first
world war and it's typically credited as
the only submachine gun that saw service
in the first world war first of all
and the first true submachine gun to see
military service so
absolutely we'd expect to see this in
bf1 and it's
well depicted the rate of fire it sort
of chugs along
as you'd expect and as it does i've been
fortunate enough to fire one of these
uh in fact if you look at the royal
armory's youtube channel we we did
some slo-mo shooting with one a few
years ago so the one thing
that sticks out is the bayonet because
although
the british derivative of the bergman
the lanchester
was designed to take the hilariously
long short magazine lee enfield bayonet
the original
german submachine gun did not have a
bayonet so
we see it in bf1 with the bayonet didn't
have one
hey quick pause i've got i've got to
quickly um whinge about the
optional accessories optical sights and
things in bf1
it makes me sad when i see bergman
with a sort of galilean optical sight on
it just doesn't make any sense
even conventional steel tube glass
lens optical sights for sniper rifles
were not super common
but all nations didn't really get around
to issuing optical sights on mass until
the last couple of years of the war this
is why i get killed in bf1 because i
insist on using period correct
setups and i'm not very good
i'm going to pause there where to start
it's a real gun as i'm sure people have
already googled
a 2.7 millimeter bullet incredibly
small and the gun itself is incredibly
small so the actual cartridge length and
is tiny as well just get it out the way
this thing would have
zero stopping power a bullet of that
incredibly lightweight traveling at that
very low speed is not pulling off
headshots
at 50 meters or whatever we just saw i
have to chuckle at the um dainty way
that the
the character handles the thing and sort
of squeezes it between his thumb and
forefinger
so as you can see as you would have seen
from other videos on this i'm sure
it is tiny it's as tiny as it's seen on
screen in fact
i think it's tinier as to how it works
in the game
yeah they've got that right imagine
doing this in uh under fire
press the magazine catch tab on the base
to pull the magazine out
and then with a tiny belt of magazines
or something
pushing a fresh one and yes it [ __ ] as
it
as it does in the game it's a real gun
um but it's not a real gun in the sense
that it doesn't kill anyone
but it might irritate them i suppose
that's how new york we have taken
objective edward
the the smle is probably the rifle i've
used most in
bf1 myself i haven't played a huge
amount of it but um
i tend to favor it because it's british
it's period correct and i like
role-playing as a hapless
british soldier who dies a lot which
means i'm running around with the the
infantry rifle with no with no scope on
it we also saw it with a scope
that was used on the canadian ross rifle
i've never seen
an smle with a warner and swayze sight
on it otherwise the smle is quite
quite well done it looks right feel
feels right the
user in this case i think it's a german
is using the bolt incorrectly
always between finger and thumb up back
and out
forward and down in almost when you see
people that know how to shoot the
bolt-action rifle especially
early enfield and with this technique
it's like
clap clap they could pretty much fire as
fast pain
shots as a self-loading rifle but of
course i'm
glad that the smelly is in there it's
iconic for for many reasons
we have lost objective hey pause
the thompson um is a definite no-no
for the first world war it was very much
a product of the first world war it was
this idea of a trench broom
colonel thompson's he coined the term
submachine gun and he had prototypes up
and running
as early as 1919 which is what roughly
we're seeing here the very first
prototype was the
annihilator which is the name that's
used in the game the model used in bf1
with the slotted
cooling forend over over the barrel is a
later prototype and it has features of
different prototypes but
given that it didn't exist at that time
in that context
it's not a huge problem to to change it
up the lack of a bus stop is
is correct for the for the time and even
the the early the the
1921 thompson you press the button the
stop comes off
the thompson's a bit of an ergonomic
nightmare certainly by modern modern
standards so the original idea of two
pistol grips
and the back end hanging out with no
stock on it and you look where you're
aiming
fits the gameplay of bf1 but um
too early for the annihilator
the burton or the winchester burton as
it's possibly more correctly known
is a really fascinating weapon there's
only one
that still exists unfortunately there's
very little in the way of archival
information that survived with it in
terms of development
trials that kind of thing as depicted in
the game sort of
it's intended as a balloon buster but
there was also
a ground roll barrel with a bayonet lug
on it um so that the the balloon bust
around would
light the thing on fire ignite the the
hydrogen within the normal bullet would
act like a normal bullet and the
bf1 seeks to depict that by having one
magazine loaded with
the incendiary rounds that do more
damage against planes
and one magazine loaded with the
anti-personnel rounds as they
effectively were
so sort of period appropriate
because it's designed in 1917 so
so correct time frame but there's only
one ever made as far as we know it never
made it as far as
the trenches or anywhere else in the
first world war the twin magazines would
give it that
absolute very steampunky appearance i
believe i just intended to give you more
ammunition on board that there'd be no
real world reason
i don't think to have one magazine with
aircraft rounds and one with infantry
but
it's a neat idea from from dice there
very cool gun to have in the game
but one of the least likely things to
get shot by
in the first world war
this is a really weird one well i didn't
notice when i first
played the the campaign on battlefield
one until i
checked uh shout out to internet movie
firearms database
who had spotted that the villa peroza
that's
in bf1 is not a villarperosa it's the
movie prop from the film the sicilian
bapti and co were and are a major
movie armorer who supply all sorts of
firearms and other stuff
to the movies and they provided this
this
mocked up villa peroza from two beretta
1938's upside down
and botched together here is a
regular not that any of these are very
regular because they're quite rare
available
now you can call it a submachine gun if
you want it's really not
the thing that makes it not a submachine
gun is the fact that it doesn't have
and never did have as far as i know a
shoulder stock so by most definitions
that would not be a sub machine gun
being two guns
welded together it's really too heavy
and awkward to be running around with
and of course you've got a you've got a
bipod hanging off the front you could
get rid of that
and um i guess that's partly why they
went with the
mock-up version in the game although
there's been no reason why they couldn't
of course model this
and remove the bipod so i don't know if
that was a mistake
or a deliberate design choice for some
reason but that's not available rosa
thanks for watching guys that was the
guns of
battlefield 1. i hope you enjoyed my
ramblings about the various
inaccuracies of those weapons and i hope
you'll join us again
for a video in the future difficult
times for
museums at the moment so if you feel you
could spare a little bit of uh
cash we do have a donation link in the
description above for the royal
armouries
um there's even a membership program um
if you'd like to
to go that route but um we just
appreciate you engaging with
our collection thank you
[Music]